A present
anniversary isn't it
there's a serial killing
first anniversary is paper
what makes you think like i'm so
cheap i thought you'd be curious
do you think i could in this
stuff don't you you have pictures
it's violence it's so baroque
oh he likes little puzzles
doesn't he so meticulous
like he's been planning this
his whole life how is he
he's a nobody wants to be somebody
the mayor the commissioner this is very very
personal he feels these people have all wronged him
probably goes way back unhealed wounds stolen lunch
money or maybe he's got a grudge against you too
maybe you're the main course any theories
oh yeah really you're normally so ahead of the curve
i'm not here to talk about me
what are you here to talk about
i want to know how he thinks you know
exactly how he thinks have you read this file
you two have so much in common
i think you don't really care about his
motors whether he loves or hates you
i think somewhere deep down you're just
terrified because you're not sure he's wrong huh
you think they deserved it
Welcome back everyone this will be
my video on the batman deleted scene
obviously this is the cutscene of the joker
that matt reeves said he would release after
the movie had come out and it just been a couple
weeks since the movie has come out in theaters
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos obviously spoiler
warning for the batman movie if you haven't seen
it yet because we'll be talking about pretty much
everything that happens during the ending and
a lot of the stuff that they reference here is
stuff that happens during the ending of the
movie you don't really care about his motors
clearly barry keoghan's joker is identifiable
as the joker like he has green hair he has the
lipstick kind of like lipstick it looks like he
kind of has white makeup too his face is probably
more scarred than i've ever seen a joker face
and there have been many versions of the joker
the scene would have happened before he went
to see the riddler for the last time like he
went to talk to the riddler the riddler gave
him his final riddle about what's black and
blue and dead all over you and he was hoping
that the batman would die during the final
attack on the election that was happening
that night but they were teasing a lot of
history during this joker scene too so they
were talking about their first anniversary
like he was talking about oh shouldn't be
stationary you get for the first anniversary
as if there was some failed crime that the
joker did that he perpetrated one year prior
that got him thrown in arkham instead of
in the regular prison first anniversary
what makes you think i'm so cheap the way that
matt reeves talked about the character is that
he hasn't fully become the joker yet like
he clearly looks like the joker but he's
not calling himself that although he was talking
to the riddler at the end about being his friend
like he gave him the riddle he used his trademark
catchphrase riddle me this implying that there
would be a riddler joker team up in the arkham
asylum tv show in a couple years whenever they
wind up getting around to making that but during
this interrogation scene he hands him a bunch of
evidence and as his expert criminal opinion
and insight into the case against the riddler
the joker mostly taunts him like he spends most
of it laughing at the batman but a lot of what the
joker says is actually what the batman realizes
as he analyzing each of the different clues at
the different envelopes that he gets from the
riddler and the conversation that he had with
the riddler which would have happened right after
this conversation one of the last things the joker
talks to the riddler about is the batman reigning
on his parade turning him into a joke but being
a joke isn't the worst thing you could possibly
be just teasing that he would eventually become
the joker but it sounds like this isn't the first
time that the batman has come to visit the joker
in arkham asylum to get information about other
criminals he's investigating or he's taking down
so it just shows you that batman is coming to
arkham asylum to interact with these batman
villains and actually have conversations
with them and get insight into these cases
it's kind of like the dark knight joker versus
batman scene where the batman is laying into
the joker trying to get information out of him
and even though the joker is getting beat up
left and right he's having as much fun as he could
possibly have with the batman he's holding all the
cards quote unquote because in the batman movie
the joker here has already figured out pretty much
everything about the riddler's mo like oh he's a
true artist are you worried that he's upstaging
you that was sort of the self-owned that batman
gave himself at the end of the movie where he
realized that vengeance wasn't enough he also had
to be a symbol of hope to all the different people
of gotham city one of the big character journeys
that he goes through during the film is trying
to find out who the batman is like the batman
himself is trying to find out who the batman is
the reason why they probably got rid of this
particular scene is because it went on for
so long and because the joker is a huge
character and you knew that you got that
tag scene at the end where you basically knew
that it was the joker so kind of served the same
purpose teasing the joker was about to become the
joker and the movie was already incredibly long so
this is bonus material you have to assume that
they'll cover on the arkham asylum tv show in a
couple years the way they talked about the arkham
asylum tv show is it'll serve as a launching point
for a couple different batman villains in his
rogues gallery but really they did so much work
setting the riddler and the joker up as the comic
pro versions of those characters or becoming the
comic book versions of those characters they'd
be a really huge bummer if they didn't pay those
off for four more years and you kind of get the
vibe between the batman and the joker here that
he hasn't really become his true villain yet he
hasn't become his true arch-nemesis the batman
doesn't really have any animosity for him he
just seems like he doesn't like to waste his time
but a lot of this information that the joker
gives you already saw through the course of
the movie so it was redundant information like he
says you and the riddler must have gone way back
bruce was already at the orphanage and he already
saw the information about how he was going after
bruce wayne next he saw the thomas wayne video he
knew the truth of the gotham city renewal fund the
billion dollar fund that his father created when
he talks about why he's writing to him like why is
he writing to me in the joker gives his answer
what i was hoping for was that the joker would
also tease the idea that the riddler had figured
out his secret identity they kind of go to batman
hush territory where the riddler starts talking
about that to batman in their final conversation
he makes him think for just a brief hot second
he's figured out his secret identity but then he
takes it right back and batman gets really pissed
off like once he realizes that his secret is still
safe that's when the riddler turns on him because
he thought that they were doing the same thing and
the joker kind of tells him that too like oh
are you worried he's upstaging you the riddler
was also on this really twisted version of a bend
trying to gain justice in the city get rid of all
these corrupt powerful people but he was killing
a lot of people in order to do it and he was going
to kill a lot more people at the election most of
you've also asked about the information released
on his website after the movie came out the rat
alada website if you go to the website now and
you click on all the information ratsalada.com
it'll give you basically all the files that he
gave to the batman that the batman had at the
end of the film there are a bunch of text easter
eggs that aren't there anymore for comic books
that are easter eggs for other characters like
twoface for instance i'll leave a link below in
the description for those videos but the message
he left for people is something is coming is
meant to be a reference to arkham asylum hbo
series the next part of the story where we'll see
more villains appear and them introduce a version
of harvey dent also pay off this joker deleted
scene if you spotted any other easter eggs in
this deleted scene that i didn't talk about during
the video just write them below in the comments
there are probably even more deleted scenes that
they'll release later when they release the movie
on home video when they do that i will do another
deleted scenes video you can click here for my
full breakdown of the batman movie and click here
for my marvel secret invasion announcement video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!